they got new york governor cuomo
resigned yesterday in disgrace a far cry
from the gushing media attention he
received along with an emmy and a five
million dollar book deal but our next
guests say the truth about his coveted
response and the people who died can not
be forgotten janisteen lost both of her
in-laws uh michael and dee took over 19
in new york nursing home facilities and
has been one of the most outspoken
voices trying to hold the former
soon-to-be former governor accountable
and then new york democratic assemblyman
ron kim lost his uncle to coven 19 in a
nursing home as well and they both join
us now good morning to both of you
good morning so janice i'll start with
you good morning janice i'll start with
you what was your reaction yesterday
i'm emotional because it's the first
time i'm seeing assemblyman ron kim who
has become really close to me and my
family over the last couple of weeks i'm
so grateful grateful grateful for him
and his uh outspokenness i mean his job
was tough you know as an assemblyman who
is democratic party and had governor
cuomo calling him and screaming at him
so i'm so grateful for you ron kim
and ron
you know we appreciate you coming on uh
over the last number of months you
listened to the governor as he resigned
yesterday after he explained how
innocent he was you say the governor
for another 13 days is delusional
explain why
i'm sorry i'll repeat that question
again i just got i'm hearing janet is
crying i'm just fairly emotional
myself
i'm sorry repeat that question you said
uh that you feel the governor is
delusional after listening to him resign
yesterday
well it wasn't an apology uh he's not
taking responsibility and that's that to
the bitter end it's reflective of the
lack of leadership
um in that in that office for so many
years the woman who had been sexually
harassed the older adults who deserve
the justice that we've been seeking
deserve a real apology with full
responsibility and that's not what we
got out of him yesterday
he warned you not to go forward with
attacking on the nursing homes he didn't
could care less about your relatives
that lost your life your uncle
that was a turning point for you instead
of being intimidated you took action
what did that do for you personally what
did you think it did for this case
and it wasn't just me in that moment
there were thousands of other families
our constituents janice's family
not lawmakers
and and i lost my uncle um a u.s army
captain
in a nursing home
died in excruciating pain by himself it
wasn't for my uncle i wouldn't be here
meaning he's the one to sponsor my
immigration paper to come to this
country so i can be part of this
american dream this this american fabric
and
and for him to die alone like that
i made a commitment that i would seek
the truth for him and for others and in
that moment when andrew cuomo tried to
get me to lie and to cover up his lies
that was the moment he crossed
from being a regular bully on a
playground to an abusive man who's
willing to abuse his power to get what
he wants
janice what did you make of the
president yesterday saying he
something to the effect of he's not a
bad man
i was policies aren't bad disappointed i
actually did a hell of a job i thought
that videotape was from last year when
he was praising him uh you know was
going to be his attorney general
i think joe biden needs to you know
learn the facts about what this governor
has done you know it's not only the
nursing homes it's not only sexual
assault sexual harassment he abused his
power to give cove family tests to his
buddies his family and his friends while
nursing homes could not get them he used
state state resources to write his book
uh and all sorts of other corruption and
i think criminal acts uh that hopefully
will be prosecuted so i was very
disappointed in joe biden yesterday you
both have said he tried to intimidate
you guys janice tell your story about
that and then uh assemblyman kim tell
your story well not like assemblyman kim
i mean i i heard from his minions you
know who said she's not a reliable
source on anything except the weather i
heard from a you know a family friend of
theirs early on who told me listen you
know you have a noble cause here but
please watch your back
uh and you know listen
social media is no fun either you know
people
saying
you know whether lady you don't know
what you're talking about but you know
ron and i had a purpose uh we are
affected personally and and that ramps
our cause up quite a bit
assembling
assemblyman
janice has been persistent through this
fight um she has been psychologically
impacted her head and her family for
months so i applaud her the fight's not
over and you know i will continue to
partner with her to get to the
accountability that we deserve
but in terms of intimidation yes my
family felt threatened by the governor
when i got that call and multiple calls
from him directly my wife couldn't sleep
for hours you know my family were
traumatized by that experience
but we came together as a family we got
support from people like janice who was
there from the beginning
to give us the strength to push back and
demand justice from this governor indeed
and speaking of justice ron
uh he's still on the hook uh you know
there are still criminal investigations
into the nursing home scandal into
whether or not state resources were used
to help write his book and
and uh so you know it he's not out of
the woods there there's still a long way
for him to go and the legislature could
vote to impeach him
that's correct and we should absolutely
do so because we already spent the
resources time and money to get this far
in the impeachment investigation so
let's finish the job let's get it done
in an efficient expeditious way to get
to the truth as an assembly and as for
his criminal act
his biggest criminal act in my opinion
is committing public fraud he suppressed
he ordered his people to suppress life
and debt data yes at the peak of the
pandemic information that we could have
used to legislate to save people's lives
he took that away from us because he was
chasing down a 5.1 million dollar book
deal
that is criminal
he's going to blame marissa derosa uh
who was on that phone call and say he
never knew nothing anything about it
finally i just believe that he's
planning a comeback already uh i do
that's why his lawyer was on first and
that's why he tries to explain himself
rather than simply resign janice do you
believe he's the i don't think this guy
is done do you
i think he's done i have to believe
we're on the side of the angels right
ron kim and i and our families he's done
ron do you think he's he thinks he's
done
he's i believe he's politically done but
knowing him he's probably thinking some
sort of a a comeback plan and it's up to
us to hold him accountable and expose
the truth so he's
he's there's no there's no way for him
to come back into the public space
especially if he gets impeached all
right i love you ron i love your family
god bless you thank you oh i love you
too jonas thank you y'all are the voices
for the people who don't have a voice
any longer god bless you both